this is the silent killer this is just  kind of normal in America people just  credited the [ __ ] out you know you want  something you put on that credit card  and what I'm concerned about is if the  economy is doing what I think it's doing  which is about to lay people off at a  serious level  you know can people make those payments  this is just we've got to get off the  drug of buying [ __ ] with  have yet and then the question becomes  why are you buying that stuff this is  the Simplicity mindset that so many  people need to head into 2023 and a lot  of people are about to learn the truth  about managing money because they're  going to be forced to like in 2008 when  so many people lost their jobs but for  the people that aren't use what's in the  air right now as a way to just get  smarter like  get off that credit card [ __ ] debt  you know really simplified get your  costs Down live more humble that's the  answer to the comments that are coming  more humble